e quem de vocês já viveu uma epidemia
eu acho que nenhum de nós passou pelo
que tá acontecendo hoje na mesmo então
eu vou voltar um pouquinho no tempo para
a gente fazer uma reflexão sobre tudo
isso que a gente tá vivendo hoje
e a pouco mais de um século a gente
viveu um epidemia e a gente eu falo como
humanidade uma epidemia que matou cerca
de 100 milhões de pessoas entre
1918/1919 esse número ele representa o
montante de mortes muito maior do que o
que foi atingido pelas duas guerras
mundiais que tivemos que foi ainda maior
do que 40 anos de epidemia que a gente
já viveu do vírus hiv
e o brasil ele não passou despercebido
durante as epidemias e por aqui cerca de
35 mil pessoas foram atingidas 5.000 do
presidente da época
se parece muito com que nós estamos
vivendo hoje não é mesmo nem tanto eu
estou me referindo da gripe espanhola e
se a gente voltar ainda um pouco mais no
tempo a gente consegue lembrar de outras
epidemias causaram tantas mortes quanto
o que a gente tem dividido hoje a gente
pode falar da peste negra a gente pode
falar da gripe sul
o mesmo falando de todas essas situações
nada se compara ao que a gente tem
vivido hoje e mais ainda tudo que
estamos vivendo é completamente novo e
não falamos apenas de nós aqui no brasil
mas do mundo como um todo
é bom essas outras academias que que
elas trazem de conhecimento para gente
e elas trazem conhecimento daquilo que
aconteceu de como nós podemos agir
dá para entender e nos prevenir de tudo
que tá acontecendo hoje e ainda assim o
nosso conhecimento ele tá sendo
consolidado dia após dia então é
importante destacar que mesmo a gente
tendo vivido situações parecidas no
passado esta com de mia é algo
completamente novo e requer da gente não
só paciência mas como também atenção
para aquilo que tem sido falado pelos
especialistas
e como pior médica incents esta eu
participei da equipe sequenciou os
primeiros genomas do coronavírus aqui no
brasil é importante destacar aqui esse
feito já foi realizado por outros países
antes do cozido do nosso mas a nossa
técnica nos permitiu sequenciais esse
genomas em apenas 48 horas e aí eu vou
contar um pouquinho dessa história para
vocês
e eu vou voltar um pouquinho no tempo do
que a gente tá vivendo hoje para vocês
entendeu como funciona a pesquisa ea
ciência durante uma pandemia
e no início de dezembro do ano passado
muito 2019 a gente ficou sabendo de
alguns casos e vim esses casos saíram na
imprensa de uma doença letal que
aconteceu lá na província derrubei na
cidade de wuhan na china como cientistas
nós estamos sempre alerta para questões
que podem nos atingir e por ter
acontecido na china e saber que a gente
tem um ambiente hoje globalizado nós já
estávamos prevendo a chegada desse vírus
aqui no brasil
e então passamos por dezembro observando
todos os números toda a epidemiologia
que estava relacionada aquele aquele
surto que inicialmente era só na china
mas que aos poucos começou a se espalhar
para outros lugares do mundo
e nesse sentido começamos a nos preparar
para a possível chegada do coronavírus
aqui no brasil
e quando voltamos do recesso de final de
ano na já tínhamos todos os reagentes
todos os os equipamentos necessários
para fazer o sequenciamento do
coronavírus caso ele chegasse aqui é bem
verdade que nós nenhum de nós queríamos
né não eu viro chegasse no brasil mas
por conta desse mundo globalizado ele
chegou e nós já estávamos preparados
e quando eu receber a notícia da
confirmação do primeiro caso era
terça-feira de carnaval muitos dos meus
amigos estavam em salvador minha cidade
natal pulando horrores atrás dos trios e
eu fui convidado então a trabalhar né
essas amostras inicialmente a gente não
sabia se ia conseguir sequencial gelol
nós temos todo o aparato necessário
e se formos então direcionados ao
laboratório no instituto adolfo lutz
e de quanto quiserem no laboratório até
a geração de geral nas 48 horas depois
foi um momento sim de muita dedicação de
muita apreensão porque todo uma
estrutura o pneu na lógica e ministerial
estava envolvida no processo
bom então trabalhamos dia e noite assim
posso dizer porque ficamos até de
madrugada naquele processo de geração do
genoa para que a gente pudesse então
trazer um resultado que fosse correto e
fidedigno para a sociedade eu faço isso
durante quatro anos todos os dias
e com outros vírus que vocês se conhecem
muito bem dengue febre amarela física
mas perfeito exatamente os primeiros
casos do novo coronavírus no brasil
trouxeram um peso muito grande tudo que
nós estávamos fazendo no laboratório e
como vocês devem saber porque vocês
devem ver as notícias todos os
cientistas do mundo estão hoje voltados
para fazer pesquisas relacionadas a
coronavírus
e muitas vezes perguntam o que é esse
gênova o que é isso que você fez o que é
esse sequenciamento e aí eu vou falar
bem basicão aqui para vocês entenderem
a sequência é um genoma nada mais é do
que descobri a sequência do material
genético que existe dentro de uma célula
o nosso organismo ele tem bilhões de
células e dentro de cada célula nós
temos uma cópia do nosso material
genético duas cópias na realidade
e essas cópias de material genético
vocês podem visualizar como se fosse uma
fita e nessa fita tem escrito duas
linhas
é e essas linhas elas são formadas por
apenas quatro letras a b g e c é o
alfabeto da vida
a cada letrinha dessa nos traz em
conjunto informações para as proteínas
que nós vamos codificar para estrutura
que nós vamos ter e elas são tão
importantes que elas dizem qual vai ser
a cor dos nossos olhos a textura da
nossa pele a estrutura do nosso cabelo
da mesma forma como nós temos essas
letrinhas nas nossas células nós também
temos essa fita dentro de um vírus
oi e o vírus utilizar essa fita com
essas letrinhas para sequenciar ou para
montar sua estrutura e dessa estrutura
ele consegue interagir com o nosso
organismo
bom então quando a gente descobre qual é
a ordem dessas letrinhas a gente está
descobrindo então qual é a estrutura que
aquele vírus vai apresentar naquele
momento específico da pandemia da
epidemia ou de um caso e doença
bom então mapear esses genoma do vírus
permite que a gente tenta como esse
vírus vai interagir com o organismo e dá
subsídios para que outros pesquisadores
farmacêuticos biólogos inclusive médicos
possam estudar não só a formação de uma
nova vacina como também medicamentos a
pastagem de medicamentos a produção de
novos medicamentos então sequenciais
gerar esse genomas o novo coronavírus
tem sido extremamente importante para
que a gente entenda como esse soro tá
acontecendo não só no nosso país como
números porque também a gente consegue
através dessa sequência rastrear como um
vírus está se diz pensando na população
bom então a gente já sabe que o
sequenciamento é importante para o
desenvolvimento de vacina para o
desenvolvimento de medicamento isso a
gente não tem dúvida apesar dos passos
até chegar na vacina serem muitos e o
tempo para que isso aconteça seja longo
a gente sabe que um dia nós vamos chegar
lá e se a gente não tem dúvida mas até
que a vacina chegue até as nossas mãos a
gente precisa entender a importância de
outras outras medidas que nós podemos
tomar que medidas seriam esses
eu vou falar de 4 termos que vocês devem
ouvir bastante distanciamento social
achatamento da curva isolamento e
etiqueta respiratória muitos de vocês
ouvirem isso vários lugares nem pela
internet mas as vezes é difícil de
compreender exatamente que cada um
desses termos significa então vou falar
para vocês quando a gente fala um
distanciamento social nós estamos
falando na redução de contato entre as
pessoas o que a gente está falando é
basicamente que vocês precisam evitar o
contato limitar o convívio social para
aqui uma doença que está vigente que
está acontecendo naquele momento tem a
sua propagação reduzida
e a com 2019 que essa doença causada
pelas novo coronavírus ela é uma doença
respiratória e por ser respiratória a
gente tem aí um grande aliado do vírus e
inimigo nosso nesse momento é o ar o ar
que a gente respira ele tá sendo um meio
de transmissão para esses vírus e ele é
fundamental a gente não pode viver sim
então a gente entra então com o novo
conceito conceito do isolamento o
indivíduo que sabidamente está doente
ele precisa se isolar e o que é se
isolar cortar qualquer tipo de contato
com outras pessoas exceto em situações
internacional internamento hospitalar ou
ainda de isolamento domiciliar quando
quem tem contato com esse de vidro está
paramentado e protegido
e a gente precisa disso durante a
pandemia a gente precisa fazer isso
quando individuais sabidamente doente
esse é o segundo termo então
distanciamento a gente reduz o convívio
no isolamento a gente evita qualquer
tipo de interação com o indivíduo eu
falei também sobre a questão do da
etiqueta respiratória e aí muita gente
me pergunta tutor a jaqueline o que é
etiqueta respiratória
e aí quem tá respiratório nada mais é do
que práticas que nós adotamos para
evitar a propagação do vírus porque nós
estamos falando de um vírus que se
transmite através de gotículas pelo ar
superfície
bom então quando nós estamos infectados
e isso pode acontecer mesmo quando não
estamos apresentando sintomas da doença
a gente vai transmitir esse vírus a
gente vai espelhe esse vírus na nossa
fala na nossa respiração ao tossir ou
espirrar e etiqueta respiratória nada
mais é do que as atitudes que a gente
toma para evitar que esse vírus que vai
sair do nosso sistema respiratório do
nosso sistema digestório sal para outra
pessoa ou para o meio então o que que eu
posso fazer eu vou evitar que essas
gotículas elas sejam lançadas para o
ambiente que se depositem em outras
superfícies então é etiqueta
respiratória ela corresponde as atitudes
que a gente toma para evitar que os
vírus sejam propagadas
bom então vocês devem ter ouvido falar
muito sobre aqueles movimentos que a
gente usa o cotovelo a dobra do braço no
momento que eu volto sim eu não faço
mais isso com a mão eu uso agora a minha
dobra do braço ah mas porque doutora
jaqueline que quando eu espirro ou torço
na minha mão e toca numa superfície eu
só fiz uma transferência do vírus daqui
para superfície mas no momento que eu
faço
e o movimento da dobra de graça então
aqui eu tô colocando o vírus no meu
próprio corpo mas numa região
normalmente não tem contato com outras
pessoas
e além disso a gente precisa lavar as
mãos a gente precisa ter hábitos de
tirar os sapatos ao entrar em casa
utilizar a roupa uma única vez se
possível um lavar as superfícies lavar
as embalagens quando ela chega em casa
tudo isso faz parte de uma etiqueta que
a gente precisa ter para evitar a
propagação do vírus então a gente já
falou de três conceitos e por último o
que que a gente precisa fazer a gente
precisa ficar em casa
bom então quando me perguntam sobre a
questão do coronavírus eu digo para
vocês é o sempre o mesmo conselho fiquei
em casa e o que é ficar em casa ficar em
casa é fazer distanciamento social fazer
isolamento quando necessário se eu tiver
doente ser aptos de etiqueta
respiratória de higiene
bom e com todas essas situações achatar
a curva
e o achatar a curva é especificamente
reduziu o número de infectados ao ponto
de a quantidade de pessoas que vão ficar
grave vou ficar doente não apresentar
sintomas estarão graves elas possam ser
atendidas pelo serviço de saúde toda
epidemia ela vai apresentar uma curva de
infecção uma curva de pessoas
contaminadas e essa curva ela vai
crescendo ao longo do tempo ela chega no
pico e depois ela pega quando a gente
pega essa curva que é muito íngreme e
diminui ou seja a chata a gente diminuir
a quantidade de dívidas que vão precisar
dos sistemas de saúde
tá fazendo o quê o que vocês tema de
saúde tenha condições de atender todos
esses pacientes e não só aqueles que
estão com coronavírus
e a gente pode ter outros indivíduos
precisando de hospitalização por outras
questões
bom então é importante que a gente tem a
noção de que quando você eu cada um de
nós ficamos em casa nós estamos
aumentando as chances daqueles
indivíduos que vão ficar graves pela
infecção pela coronavírus possa trazer
e essa essa possibilidade de atendimento
no hospital então eu permito que o outro
seja atendido e eu facilita o processo
de cura dessas pessoas então ficar em
casa é fazer distanciamento social
cumprir com o isolamento pela etiqueta
respiratória e reduzir ou achatar a
curva de infecção
e por isso a melhor forma de costureira
anemia é se distanciando das pessoas e
não se expondo a riscos porque o perigo
ele é invisível
e eu quero que vocês pensa em todos os
profissionais estão aí nos serviços
essenciais que abdicaram das suas
famílias que abdicaram da segurança
biológica todos os dias para que as
nossas vidas possam voltar ao novo
normal não é o que a gente conhece mas é
um novo normal por isso eu peço mais uma
vez que se possível fiquei em casa